راتا قبل بضع دقائق فقط
كنت مستلقياً هنا ، لا أصدق
أنك وقفت العديد من التهاني
التي كانت شديدة وكان ذلك مرهقًا
كان من الواضح أنه كان عاطفيًا للغاية بالنسبة لك ،
كيف تصف الساعات الخمس الأخيرة
من حياتك أو  لقد كانت
بطريقة دراماتيكية ، حيث كان للمباراة كل شيء
، وعضو دانيال ، نعم ، أحد
أقوى المنافسين وأفضل
اللاعبين في العالم بالطبع ، وهذا
يعني الكثير بالنسبة لي لامتلاك هذا الكأس في
يدي ، ولم أقاومه جيدًا خلال
الساعات الثلاث الماضية  من المباراة التي لعبها بشكل
مذهل ، أعتقد بالنسبة لي شخصيًا أن
الرضا الشخصي هو مثل هذا
المنافس الهائل في بعض الأحيان
، لكنك في نهاية
المباراة عندما شاهدت مقطع الفيديو لجميع إنجازاتك
كنت عاطفيًا للغاية
لماذا تعتقد أن رد الفعل بهذه
الطريقة جيدًا لا أعلم أنه من
المستحيل أحيانًا التحكم في الحركة لا وأحاول
المقاومة لكنها كانت صعبة وأعني
كل هؤلاء الأشخاص يدعمون الطريقة التي  القبعة
التي تتطابق معها أصبحت تعرف
إرهاق الجسد وعلى الجانب العقلي
أيضًا ، لذا فإن كل هذه الأشياء تجعل هذه الأشياء
تُنسى بالنسبة لي.